The fight is done
we lost
stay hidden
the key
to hunting jedi
this patience
this jedi cannot help what
they are their compassion
leaves a trail
the jedi code is like an itch
Hello there everyone this is going to be my
star wars obi-wan kenobi trailer video they
finally dropped footage so we'll break it all
down there's a whole bunch of easter eggs here
obviously darth vader in the background duel
of the fates they are doing all the things and
it looks like it's going to be amazing if you're
new to the channel i will be doing episode videos
just like i do for all the other star wars disney
plus series be sure to subscribe to get them all
i'll start at the beginning of the footage and
we'll just work our way through scene by scene
talking about easter eggs wtf moments and i will
explain what's going on during the actual series
we know a little bit about what's going on in
the plot but the big thing here is they obviously
spin up into like an alternate version of duel of
the fates this is meant to pick up about 10 years
after the end of revenge of the sith in order 66
some of the series will revisit moments from order
66 i think maybe some flashbacks because part
of the idea in bringing hayden christensen back
as darth vader is that just like during rogue
one you'll see him without the helmet on so
you'll recognize that it is hayden christensen
under the makeup but i believe that also might
be doing some flashbacks or obi-wan kenobi
might be having nightmares and flashbacks to
order 66 where we'll see hayden christensen as
anakin skywalker before he lost the high ground
other big thing i was surprised to see that they
actually brought a young version of luke skywalker
onto this now we did see luke skywalker during the
mandalorian during the book of boba fett so there
is a lot of skywalker happening in the star wars
disney plus series all across the timeline but
like i said because it's 10 years after revenge of
the sith luke skywalker is only about 10 years old
pretending to bullseye womp rats in a fake t-16
here sitting on top of owen and peru lars hut
the way ewan mcgregor talks about obi-wan kenobi
at the beginning of the series here is that 10
years into his mission to lay low and just watch
over luke skywalker he's about giving up on life
like he's just completely dejected i believe
it's what's going on with the inquisitorius the
grand inquisitor and the inquisitors going around
the jedi hunters and darth vader that eventually
inspires him to leave the planet like his big
call to action there are rumors that it's going
to involve a princess leia plot like they're doing
young luke skywalker 10 years old there'll also
be a 10 year old princess leia that will show up
during the series at some point in a cameo scene
so it's not like they're just doing young luke and
not doing young leia but i believe the reason why
he leaves tatooine has something to do with that
and the inquisitors because later in the trailer
you do see obi-wan kenobi fighting the inquisitors
on this other planet i'll explain where that is
in a second but the actual opening scene of the
trailer is him riding across the sands of tatooine
on the eop animal here now because his hut was
built over here on the other side of the gentleman
waste from owen and beru lars moisture farm i'm
assuming that he's either headed to most espa
or they've changed it because like you see him
right here perched up across the moisture farm
watching luke skywalker if this cave that he's
living in here is way closer to their moisture
farm the town that he's going to might actually be
most eisley most obviously an anchor head are just
much closer to the moisture farm than most espa
most espos like on the other side of tatooine
closer to where his hut was during the events
of a new hope but it looks like at this point
in the timeline he hasn't fully built his hut yet
we spent a lot of time in mos eisley and in most
espa during the mandalorian season 1 season 2 and
then during the book of boba fett episodes but you
have to remember that the events of those episodes
are taking place like 18 19 years after what's
happening here during the opium kenobi series
just charting the timeline this is ten years
after revenge of the sith but the band delorean
in the book of boba fett pick up five years after
return of the jedi they did bring joel edgerton
back as owen large he said that he was surprised
that they called him like thank you for casting
me george lucas and thank you for bringing me back
this many years later and it's also the same
actress who played beru lars during revenge
of the sith so they brought back everybody they
could then we meet the inquisitors the fortress
here that they fly to is literally called the
fortress inquisitorius it's where they train all
the inquisitors is on one of the moons of mustafar
called nur and part of it is submerged underwater
here like you can see when they're meeting in
this room here they are submerged underwater
darth vader's castle built on mustafar darth
vader's castle was actually built to sort of take
advantage of the dark side ley lines and the force
like those giant spike structures aren't just for
show those are actually tuning forks for the dark
side so while he's busy stewing in his castle here
just getting really pissed off getting ready to go
around hunt jedi around the galaxy the inquisitors
are busy training their forces over in this castle
on the moon nearby we meet a couple of the main
character inquisitors there's a lot of them but
only a couple of them will be main characters
this one is called riva we don't know a lot about
her backstory or how she became an inquisitor
but this is the first time she's shown up in the
canon the characters that you will recognize are
the grand inquisitor from star wars rebels he's
not being played by jason isaacs though this is
actually rupert friend underneath the makeup but
he's got that same weird double bladed lightsaber
that he had from star wars rebels this character
kind of looks like the fifth brother also from
star wars rebels this is the first time that we've
seen the inquisitors in live action though but the
whole idea is that we knew that darth vader went
around hunting the jedi that escaped order 66
right after the event of revenge of the sith but
it was until star wars rebels that they introduced
the idea of the inquisitors to the canon like
dave filoni created the inquisitors themselves
so they're a relatively new addition to the star
wars canon the whole idea with the inquisitors is
that they're either former jedi who were turned by
the emperor turned to the dark side by choice or
they were children who were force sensitive that
the emperor stole from their families and then
twisted to the dark side and raised as inquisitors
they did a little bit of that plot during the
clone wars episodes the special name that he
had for that program the inquisitor program was
project harvester i believe the grand inquisitor
used to be one of the jedi temple guardians at the
jedi temple on coruscant before order 66 before
the emperor turned the old jedi temple into his
imperial palace you also learned a little bit
more about the inquisitors during the jedi
fallen order storyline of that game darth vader
had a weird relationship with the inquisitorius
the whole idea with darth vader is that he
actually went around killing every jedi that
he could find every force sensitive he could find
not because he hated the idea of force sensitives
it was mostly because he didn't want the emperor
training another replacement and then getting rid
of him because that's exactly what he did with
darth maul they were always plotting against each
other the emperor always knew that darth vader
would eventually betray him and darth vader never
trusted the emperor and was always searching for
a way to get rid of him keep your friends close
but your enemies closer when the grand inquisitor
is talking about the key to hunting jedi is about
following this trail of compassion basically he's
talking about hurting people so the jedi will come
save these people and then out themselves in
the process it seems like owen large runs the
foul of the inquisitor something bad happens in
town while they're on tatooine the whole idea is
that they're not looking for luke skywalker on
tatooine the inquisitors don't know about him
but they do know that obi-wan kenobi survived the
purge so they're actually on tatooine probably
because they're looking for obi-wan kenobi this
also helps provide more context for why during
the events of a new hope owen lars is so against
telling luke skywalker the truth about his father
anakin skywalker and telling him the truth about
obi-wan kenobi he'll witness all these terrible
things that the inquisitors do on tatooine to all
the regular people this is the inquisitor reba on
that new planet that i was talking about so this
is a brand new plan they introduced during the
series it's called daiyu they said it's a little
bit like space hong kong all these neon signs are
written in the standard star wars common language
of arabesh this is indira varma you might remember
her as one of the sand snakes from game of thrones
she's just playing a normal imperial officer
based on what we know about the plot i'm assuming
that obi-wan kenobi starts on tatooine and then
comes to this other planet because of the
mission that he's on whoever it is that he's
trying to save that's the whole point of the grand
inquisitor's speech about the jedi not being able
to help themselves this very strict code that
they follow he gets into a big blaster fight on
the rooftops here with the other inquisitors you
have to picture him saying blaster so uncivilized
riva pulls out her sith lightsaber the whole
idea with lightsabers is that there are no red
lightsaber crystals like when you become a sith
you don't just go find a red lightsaber crystal
you have to turn a regular lightsaber crystal
to the dark side so you take a white a yellow
a blue lightsaber crystal you twist it to the
dark side and it turns red the symbol that one
of the jedi hunters is touching is the symbol
of the jedi order even though we only hear darth
vader's breathing sounds over the trailer there is
supposed to be a couple of big rematches between
obi-wan kenobi and darth vader even though
canonically there's a lot of questions about
that but based on the concept art they actually
do have a rematch during this series and they're
just taking a different interpretation of their
phrasing when they talked about their rematch
during a new hope it would be weird to bring them
both back in a series and then not let them have a
bunch of scenes together they're probably holding
back on actual darth vader in the trailers until
like the next big trailer that'll also give us
much more of the actual story this is just meant
to give you a vibe for what the series is going
to feel like the music and big reminder too if
you didn't realize john williams actually kind
of came out of star wars retirement so to speak
to do a new theme song for the obi-wan series so
i am expecting him to bake some duel of the fates
into that new obi-wan theme song then big reminder
the episodes are going to start on may 25th that's
going to be around the time star wars celebration
is happening so they will probably have a really
big obi-wan kenobi panel at star wars celebration
this year i believe there's supposed to be between
four and six episodes they haven't been really
clear on that it was originally gonna be six but
then they said it was gonna be four now if you
visit the wiki it says six episodes so we'll see
but everyone post all your reactions in the
comments below post all your obi-wan kenobi
memes let me know what do you think of the series
so far but if you have any big questions about
what's happening during the series what's
going on with the canon in this part of the
timeline and how this is going to connect with
any of the other series remember it's 10 years
after revenge of this so it's mostly going to
be riffing on revenge of the stuff i will do
more trailer videos when we get more footage
everyone click here for my mandalorian season
3 teaser trailer video and click here for that
brand new marvel shangshi deadpool deleted scene
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!